l'humour promenade à l'excès de sérieux
tristan bernard et qui vas y mon risque
concernant ben c'est bien c'est une
belle citation et foxconn
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le moa le plus court chemin d'un homme à
un autre
je joue un ski dessinateur le plus
proche mais c'est l'année droite la
ligne droite et le coucher mais du point
de l'arrivée
donc je crois qu'il a un peu piratés
parce que ça c'est une citation
africaine dit
dans le mot c'est pas une ligne droite à
le monde sait d'autre une histoire
l'histoire en lots intrinsèquement c'est
pas forcément drôle mais nous comme on
avait eu maurice comme un conte prend la
vie du bon côté on a les bateaux de
l'histoire à cause de mon accent et du
mal à trouver un appartement quand
j'appelle des gens me disent on se
rappelle avait pas et moi sur la peine
de savoir où ils vont pas rappelé disons
qu'on vous aidera à combler je n'ai même
pas reconnue vous aider aussi je me suis
mise beaucoup de refus de visas est
j'ai été patient ça m'a jamais trompé
d'aller passer collectivement par la
méditerranée parce que j'ai toujours
peur du loup toujours paiement 2010 chez
moi mon exemple mon histoire du visa
c'était pas facile il ya des rues même
j'ai pleuré mais aujourd'hui j'en rigole
parce que j'ai compris que si cette
histoire m'a fait pleurer si j'ai tort
ça bon ça peut mieux faire et haut débit
sans cesse à faire les autres quand je
vais déposer mon dossier pour ma carte
de séjour
je vais préciser que j'ai joué à
l'institut du monde arabe
et vu la taille du monde arabe c'est que
ça représente pour les français pour moi
je crois que je vais taper là donc ils
sont très contents ou les potes et ça ça
m'a comme on le dit à quoi doit sa
médaille des justes et moi quand je
compte sur cette gen a besoin de dire
aux gens qu'on n'existe pas besoin de
dire aux gens qu'ils existent parce que
on sur scène raconte un petit souci en
scène par là pour dire que l'on existe
mais moi ce que je fais sur scène pour
jouer sur scène dans les dirigeants
j'évite de ceux qui par un visuel commun
mais existe une des maladies de santé
mais je vais bien sûr je ne peux me
débrouiller pour son aîné midi
allez je vais garder les finances où les
victimes at étonne pas d'être aux
alarmes et j'en suis dingue au boléro
vraiment l'impression d'exister parce qu
on se sent écouté sur scène sans écouter
les gens qui suppose qu'on raconte
il ya des blagues conques les gens là
aussi et c'est vrai que ça nous ça nous
fait prendre conscience que à part le
valais les autres quand on sait ce que
je ressens quand je sors de 58 sur scène
en parle à un public qui lui a montré
que l'on nous écoute et capable de
parler d'humour c'est une plaisanterie
avec un air triste
william shakespeare que reste-il et
j'aime beaucoup j'adore williams s'est
pas de rôle les trucs joyeux là aucun
truc drake et drôle enfin en vrai je
trouve donc oui bien sûr on se nourrit
de toutes nos fins moi personnellement
je me nourris de toutes mes névroses et
dieu sait qu'elles sont nombreuses et je
me nourris de tous les trucs que de
loose qui est qu'ils ont pu m'arriver
bonmalais les juifs marocains font que
les catholiques imi soir on a envie
d'être le seul point commun entre ces
deux cultures et des bibelots livres et
c'est ça ce qu'on aime voir on aime voir
le dans les procédés plus anciens on
aime bien le lisais sur la part dont il
sait sur la peau de banane tu vois après
s'il lui arrivait que des trucs super
qu'ils venaient
du jour au lendemain qu'il épousait une
joueuse incroyable et qu'il avait tout
ce qu'ils voulaient qu'il est tombé du
ciel
y a rien de drôle on dirais pas ça
provoquerait de l'an viii de la jalousie
mais pas comment dire pas un système de
reconnaissance aussi de son propre vécu
et de l'humour ça faire vraiment aussi à
dédramatiser de plein de choses
effectivement un peu plus un peu plus on
croit qu'il peut nous arriver
l'humour est le meilleur détecteur de
mensonges c'est vrai qu'en ethnologue
autrichien je trouve cela très juste
parce que
quelque part sur scène on ne peut pas
mentir
et quand on fait des blagues et que
c'est pas drôle c'est parce que c'est
généralement c'est en ce moment et je
pense que les verts passage que j'ai pu
faire c'est quoi au juste et la vérité
aux gens on sent de suite quand un
humoriste il essaye de faire des blagues
pour juste favori et pas les sens a dit
d'animer un but du monde on est
champions du monde les arabes ont été au
top
j'étais à 2 août 13 novembre at on tape
j'étais noir de vous je pense que vous
pondre de chaque et mourir
il ya une personnalité et les
personnalités
c'est ça qui fait qu'on est mou sauf m
mais ces deux là sont des couples r je
donc c'est notre sérieux notre
nous-mêmes de base quand décuple pour
faire leurs échantillons je parle de mes
origines puisque ce vendredi des
questions pourquoi je suis voilà c'est
quoi tes origines hongroises à sur scène
il ya plein de choses en fait j'essaie
de répondre aux questions qu une longue
pause est avant que avant qu'il me l'a
présenté l'humour c'est aussi une façon
de résister guy bedos rigoriste je fais
les bas et surtout les os l'humour est
une arme saxo bank en tiens à dire
une population ou souvent une langue qui
est qui a eu du mal à exister une des
armes c'est l'humour c'est produire des
spectacles d'humour faire rire les gens
ça fait exister des langues qui sont en
bois revenir la disparition ne parle
plus beaucoup ces héros glace alors ma
première chanson et quelques chansons de
tolérance j'aimerais dédier donc
président nord-coréen kim jong un
et à son père kim jong il et à sa mère
kim jong réel et à tous ses frères et
soeur de kim jong un son de l'ordination
je trouve que c'est une arme très très
très important en résistance parce que
aller au pied le cas est plus fort que
toi et or là il ya des armes je sais pas
il a poussé et trois tueries de relever
en fait il peut pas ça sur le but c'est
de toi tes peurs mais le rire c'est une
arme qui va au delà de ces y peut rien
faire et le rire engendre de livres ça
qui peut rire avec toi et quant à lui
dans un bain
[Musique]